une énième soirée de violence qui a
laissé des traces
durant une heure dimanche soir un groupe
d'une cinquantaine d'individus à semer
le trouble dans le quartier de la petite
hollande en prenant à partie les forces
de l'ordre
une nouvelle épreuve pour les habitants
qui oscillent entre crainte et
exaspération
c'est plus sérieux un ras-le-bol qu'une
crainte vers 30 la crainte de co2
c'est une violence gratuite c'est tout
c'est pas à telle façon qu on obtient
quelque chose mon emploi sont de quelle
façon qu'il casque et qui est des
grattes c'est invivable
moi j'ai un petit chien c'est sûr
qu'après sept heures du soir si vous
faites agresser insulter l'autre chose
commune mon garage j'ai pris un coup de
barre de fer dans le dos c'est agir up à
montbéliard le quartier de la petite
hollande est le théâtre de violences
urbaines depuis des mois les élus ont
déjà réagi et a alerté le gouvernement
mais malgré l'intervention régulière des
forces de police les violences ne
cessent toujours pas le point
d'amélioration encore le point
d'attention encore de notre dispositif
c'est que nous n'avons pas réussi hier
soir à faire des interpellations
donc ça c'est un regret de matha nous
avons travaillé avec le service pour
pouvoir continuer à améliorer nos
techniques comment peut-on accepter que
50 individus pourrissent la vie de 8000
un moment il faut mettre fin à ces
groupuscules qui qui terrorise
la population qui fait que l'on fait et
bien les gens qui se comportent
correctement donc une envie c'est
d'aller habiter ailleurs et ça ce n'est
pas normal
dimanche soir les réactions des forces
de l'ordre a été rapide
dix patrouilles de police et de
gendarmerie se sont rendus sur place
elles seront renforcées dès ce lundi par
des effectifs supplémentaires dès ce
soir le préfet du département du doubs a
obtenu le renfort d'une compagnie de crs
donc une demi compagnie il sera déployé
sur la za sppe et ce à partir de ce soir
ans le nombre de jours et il est très
variable peuvent partir une journée
revenir le lendemain ça c'est l'emploi
des crs qui le détermine mais dès ce
soir il y aura effectivement une
présence crs sur la zad aspect si aucune
interpellation n'a pour l'instant eu
lieu dans le quartier
une enquête a été ouverte ce lundi par
le parquet de montbéliard